[MUSIC PLAYING]
HA: People are surprised that MIT has a public art
program and it's been going on since 1965, really.
We think of the entire
campus as a museum
and we have over 66
large-scale permanent art
installed throughout campus.
UPITIS: We are known to be a technology school.
However, ever since World War II,
MIT has really thought of the arts as important, both
in terms of curricular but
also in the life on campus
and the life of the students.
Alexander Calder's The Big Sail from 1965
is MIT's first major
commission of public art.
Calder's Big Sail
really has this function
of humanizing the
post-war MIT campus.
This is a term that MIT
administration used in support
of why there were arts at MIT
this idea of humanizing
scientists and technologists.
President Wiesner was
an enormous supporter
of art at MIT.
And he was integral
in MIT's adoption
of a Percent for
Art policy, which
allocates a portion of
every building project
or major renovation budget
to new art in a public space
on the campus.
And this policy was passed
in 1968 by President Johnson.
MIT's Percent for Art is very
rare for a private university.
It is the oldest in the country
and one of the very few.
HA: In 1975, the IM
Pei Chemistry Building
was the first Percent
for Art program.
And that was a Louise Nevelson.
UPITIS: IM suggested
Nevelson as the artist
to create a work for the
newly-built Building 66.
And it is her second
public art commission.
She had just started
working at that scale.
When the work was
installed, it was actually
placed in the students'
volleyball court.
And students had no
idea this was happening.
And students became quite
irritated and a series of hacks
ensued.
HA: We learned a valuable
lesson with that.
And so we do involve
students now in our process.
What I find so exciting and
fantastic about MIT is in a way,
we collect art and architecture.
As you walk around,
you are surrounded
by creativity and the
physical presence of art.
Buildings like the
Frank Gehry, the Stata,
which is an artificial
intelligence and computer
science building.
Or the Stephen Hall Building,
which is a residence.
It really is just an amazing
gift to the visitors.
UPITIS: Dan Graham's Yin
Yang Pavillion is from 2003.
It takes the form of
a very large yin yang.
Students have really engaged
with the piece in a very MIT
way, they placed
small rubber duck's
in the water portion
of the work, which
can be a challenge in terms
of maintaining the work.
But the artist
actually really enjoys
this gesture of interaction
on the part of the students.
HA: For those who know
about the MIT Percent
for Art Program and the
public art collection,
it is considered world class.
But one of the messages
I want to get out
is that most Bostonians don't
know that this public art
exists here.
And it's free.
Always open to the public.
And so we want everyone to
know about the collection.
[MUSIC PLAYING]